[Music]
hey there
and welcome to this uh training series
on
color which i love color uh hopefully
chuck checked out the examples
i showed in the previous video if you
haven't checked those out please go
check those out before we jump into this
um but uh for this example i am going to
show you how i created
this animation that i call angel this is
an animation i created a while back
and i posted on youtube and i got a lot
of really good response from it people
wanted to know
how i made this in after effects so i
thought this would be a great example to
show you guys
uh how to create inside of after effects
um what's great about this example is
it's using
all of the principle all of the
principles we have talked about
uh in the previous weeks so there's line
in there which we obviously can see here
this is you know the lines
going on circular lines these
uh triangle lines and these upside down
lines
and there's also repetition going on and
the repetition is obviously seen
right here with duplicated lines one
that's
uh scaled larger than the other
there's also color going on which we're
going to talk about today which you can
see in this
gradient from purple to blue
plus the color that's going on in the
halo and these lines
um and there's also texture going on and
the texture
is a little bit different it's a noise
texture
found in the lines it's this smoky
texture
what this is this is using the saber
plug-in which is a free
plug-in from video copilot
and in the plug-in it's got this
built-in feature called i believe
distortion
um which the distortion uh feature
can be used in different ways and for
this example i used it as kind of like a
noisy fog texture so we're using
everything we've learned so far plus
color to create this example that i call
angel so
like previous weeks i'm going to give
you the project file to download
this actual project that you're seeing
now but we're going to recreate this
today and it may not look exactly the
same it may look better it may look
worse
it's always interesting to find out how
it's going to look
but that's the fun in this you're going
to get both projects this project
plus the one we're going to do right now
so let's
jump into it
so the first thing i'm going to do is
create a new composition which we're
going to make this
20 48 by 1080 24 frames a second
and we'll call this angel 2.
and that animation was actually longer
is 20 seconds so we'll make this one 20
seconds as well
there's our composition these are the
assets i used in the original
um angel but there are certain ones we
can't use so like i can't
legally give you this fog uh this is
from another company called lens
distortions where i purchased a fog
pack um but i've got a solution to that
so we'll start with the
angel okay so the angel is all it is
is a photograph that i found
[Music]
in creative commons as we've talked
about
and i cut out uh the the background
so this is just an angel that i have cut
out in photoshop
um cut the edges out um i think i
actually use the magic wand magic
selection tool to select the background
i'm not going to get into that there's a
million ways you can cut things out in
photoshop
you probably know how to do that but
yeah the angel is just a photograph
and we're going to add a new camera
we'll use a one node camera click okay
35 millimeter is fine
and we're going to back this camera up
so that we can see i'm just clicking the
c
tool as we've done in previous weeks um
and we're going to click p
select p on the keyboard set a keyframe
and
maybe push in on it like so
i think i'll start a little bit further
back
the one thing i didn't want to show in
this is the platform it's standing on
because when you see that
platform it gives kind of throws our
perspective off right because this is
angled back so i didn't want to see that
so i was
careful to not show that
but i also want to show the feet as much
as possible
[Music]
so maybe that's not too bad right there
and based upon that this is already this
zooms in too much i don't want too much
of a
camera move if it's just flying in
really quick it's just gonna you know
not
it's not as powerful when the camera is
just like flying at you
maybe pushing a little bit more
hit the c key and we'll just
pedestal up
so that's not bad for a camera move okay
cool
um so what i used in the background was
this image called frosty background
which i'll drop in here make it 3d as
well
i'm actually going to push it back in z
space
doesn't have to be exact that's probably
too much actually
let's push it back about 500 pixels um
i'm gonna scale it
up so it covers the entire and this
could be
any image back here um i just
liked this when i was playing around i
liked how this looked
okay that looks pretty good
and the reason i am backing this image
up um as you see if i scroll through
this
i don't want to look like they're the
same image i want some some parallax to
happen there so i'm going to actually
push it
back farther scale it up again
so now let's move through this so now
you can see
the statues more in the foreground it's
very subtle
but the background is not moving with
the statue
okay so now let's make it um let's
actually turn
let's actually make a background do a
layer new solid
and make it the column size put it in
the background
and i want to make this statue
[Music]
come from the dark like you see here and
then
get brighter right like it's getting lit
up
um there's a few different ways you
could do this
one way is to use a light a 3d light
we're going to do this a little
differently this time we're going to use
a simple effect
called levels color correction
levels and this is all going to be trial
and error here
but let's just start
so the thing is i want see already it's
already looking
interesting here so this is without
levels and then width and i've crushed
the blacks
which is this far left slider
and this middle slider is the gray
values right and the far
right is the whites or the highlights
so i'm just gonna mess with these a
little bit
and that's pretty cool i like that
so now to set a keyframe we just click
on this uh stop
though we just click on the stopwatch
for the histogram
and click u on our layer and there's our
keyframe
and we can come back and um
i could reset it and you can see it
added a keyframe here
but that's way too bright right even in
the final
frame you can see it's still pretty dark
so this looks like it was lit outside
during the day which it was
it was a photograph from the daytime so
let's make it look a little more
dark and to do that
it's mostly going to be in the gray
values here
oh i don't know we'll come back and
adjust as necessary but
maybe something right there be
interesting
so it's dark and it gets lit up
okay let's try that cool
so next let's get this uh kind of pink
and blue color going on here on the
statue
on the angel okay what i used to
originally do that was a red giant
plugin
[Music]
that i am going to skip and i'm going to
instead use the
sapphire plugin so in the original
version that you can download you'll see
that you're probably missing a sapphire
universe plugin
um i'm just going to plug the universe
plugins really quickly
i love the universe plugins um
i use these plugins all the time
for this stylecraft membership i'm
trying to stay away from them so much so
you guys don't have to invest
more money but you are going to get a
discount code for
red giant um that i've mentioned in
previous videos
and you're going to say 50 off of
universe and i think that takes that
down to the price of 50 dollars
and that's a one year subscription 110
worth the money so if you're willing to
spend 50 bucks
when i give you this code coming up
pretty soon get universe
just to show you what plugin i
originally used i believe it's under
universe generators yeah gradient ramp
and i just changed it from two color to
three color and then i started doing my
thing
so we're not going to use that like i
said today we
instead are going to use a one from
sapphire
and to do that let's click in
or type in gradient and we'll go into
sapphire
um maybe gradient multi
yeah so gradient multi defaults to three
colors which is perfect
so the three colors are going to be
pink ish
and then
we'll do blue
fish and then we're gonna do pink again
so i'll just
do that right there okay cool so
let me go back to the beginning here and
what i did
was i set a keyframe for the point
of point one point three
and
point three will start out here
and point one we'll start out here
so essentially what this is doing is
it's making it look like it's just
all blue to begin with
and then we'll go to the end here and
we're gonna bring it in
give it some some pink there
[Music]
some pink there i need to adjust
point of 0.2 which i'll put kind of here
well that's not gonna work
maybe something like this i'm just
experimenting here
i don't know we'll have to see how this
looks
so then what we need to do is we need to
um
tell this gradient how to act with the
angel
and we're going to do that by going to
multiply yes there we go
so big difference from grad
only gradient only to multiply
boom
so there you go so it starts kind of
blue very dark
what's really cool about this is you can
just see the highlights here
um which i might want to do a little bit
more now with the levels
just so i can see yeah
a little bit more of the highlights and
then boom
right there
i don't know something like that's kind
of cool
so it comes in just like so
cool okay so the next thing we're going
to do now is start adding these
these lines these saber lines right
so to do that we're just going to go to
layer new solid
we're going to call this oh triangle
[Music]
01 so saber requires
a mask for it to work so what i'm going
to do is go up to my mask
tools here my shapes i'm going to select
polygon tool
double click there it is
i'm going to now select this point and
this point i'm gonna hit delete
i'm gonna select this point and this
point and
double click and then i'm gonna hold
down
uh command and i'm gonna drag these
points out
like so doesn't have to be perfect
then i'm going to click all the points
again double click
and hold down shift command again to
scale down
and i don't know maybe do something like
so
that'll work for now so now we've got a
mask on there i'm going to go back
to my effects i'm going to go down to
video copilot
saber like i said this is a free plugin
i've linked to it in the description
below the video um
but we're going to go into customized
core
saber we're going to change this to
layer masks
and there we go see it recognizes the
mask
that was drawn on the solid so
pretty cool pretty cool um one thing i
might do is i'm going to go up to
presets
and i don't remember what i selected i
like to go through these
and just kind of find one that's you
know interesting
that's really crazy
maybe i'll go back to fire maybe i will
use that
oh no let's see how this looks it's
really
crazy
i'm gonna preview this really quickly so
there's our example um with the fire
it's cool but it's too crazy for me
right
so um i am going to just go back to what
i originally did
um which i think i just did the default
and what i did here was i sampled the
color
[Music]
from the blue which i'm going to get off
of this
select command c to copy
go back into my triangle and paste
so i'm just going to go from blue
all the way at the somewhere
probably in here actually at the end and
i'll go back to the pink
which select that copy
and go into the triangle and paste
right so that's kind of cool
uh one thing you'll immediately see is
that the triangle is not
moving because it's not a 3d layer so
we'll make it move
and we need to scale it up
let's see here
so that's cool
and i'll bring it down and i also want
it to offset just slightly from the
angel
and its movements parallaxing so that
angel's at zero
um the frosty background's at 2100 so
maybe just something slight like i don't
know
500
something like so
and let's see how it looks looks pretty
cool
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to do the off we're going to end
offset it so
because you saw the line draw on
so we'll start it at zero
and we're going to finish it at
well maybe 90 percent
and also what i did here was i uh
started
the offset instead of at zero
i started it in a different spot
which may be right in there
actually i like how that looks
start there move across
boom like so
okay cool so that's interesting
what i did next is i duplicated this
triangle layer
i'll call this triangle two
and i took
this original mask i scaled it up just
slightly
like so
and i can't see it because the triangle
mask above it needs to be set to screen
there we go and what i did on this
triangle too is i actually reversed
uh the color so we will go into the
color we'll select both keyframes
we're going to right click and say
keyframe assistant time reverse
keyframes
so they're going to look slightly
different yeah that's cool and we're
also going to set this screen
this bottom triangle to screen as well
okay works for me
and on triangle two we're also going to
take this mask
and we are going to duplicate the mask
double click hold down shift rotate
we're gonna bring it down somewhere
in here like so
so that's cool one thing we do need to
do now is add that atmospheric texture
right to these saber layers and
how i did that was i went into
distortion
[Music]
and i turned up the glow distortion you
see that it immediately
pops on like that
it's set to smoke there's fluid and
there's energy as well
um you can control the speed uh the
noise speed all that i think i cranked
these
way down maybe .5.5
went into the first triangle and also
did the same thing where i
turned the glow distortion
up slightly and turned it
down to 0.5 0.5
um i actually also added a little bit of
flicker
to these so maybe 40 percent
and maybe 30
now let's go ahead and turn this
background image
on and obviously the problem with this
background is it's way too bright right
so we'll go
into effect color correction levels
again
and let's just bring this way down
yeah because what i like about this
image is that it has this
noise right but it's not all over the
place so this is way more interesting to
me
the first thing i see though i have a
problem here is that you can see
saber is cutting off here
it looks like it's that one
it's also way too bright
so i'm going to scale this layer up
and then i'm going to double click the
mask
scale it down like so
and then i'm going to go back up into
the glow intensity turn that way down
maybe like 20 21
well
let's turn the core size down to one
that's cool it's very thin lines i like
that though
yeah that's cool okay so another thing i
did is i added a
halo and i did that by just doing the
same thing i added a new solid
i'll call it halo and
i'm actually going to create a circle
mask with the ellipse tool
and i just faked the perspective on this
guy
doesn't have to be perfect
set a keyframe there
should also the keyframe right there
right there make this layer 3d
make it bigger now
go to the end actually let me delete
that
and i'll make this we're going to make
it rise
up like so i need to make the layer
appear you saw the layer was cutting off
there
so well something like that
go to effect video copilot
saber and
customize the core to a layer mask right
and let me turn this halo to screen
as well
so right now it looks like it's moving
uh actually it's opposite which i kind
of actually like that
the halo is coming down onto
her head you can see here the top of the
image again
is cutting into the image i'm gonna drag
that up
oh maybe like that
and then we'll bring it the mask down
just slightly
like that
and on the original version i actually
did like an orange color up there
but i like this better i actually like
how these lines are also
brighter which is interesting
and so this makes the halo look like
it's like you're literally lighting up
her head right um but you see up here
the top of her head is purple the halo's
blue so we need to
change the halo color
back to this kind of pinkish color
yeah it works a little bit better
that's cool um one thing i'm going to do
right away is i'm going to add a new
adjustment layer
and we are going to add some noise and
grain we'll add
grain to this one
final output
so with green without
yeah there's our grain very cool
okay i'm going to preview this and so
i'm previewing here and it's
looking cool but there are some things
about it i don't like
um one of the things i don't like is
that it takes
too long for uh the angel to go from
blue to pink
and i also don't like how this line is
crossing in the halo
the halo is moving too slow so i can't
even tell it's coming down
so lots of little details i'm going to
fix here so actually let's start with a
halo
click u on the keyboard and
one way to fix this is just to do a
keyframe easy ease
in go to my graph and just stretch it
out here
so if i was to solo this you're gonna
see
a bit of half rez
so there it is moving
[Music]
it's still too slow right at the
beginning you can see it kind of come
down
um so let's fix that let's actually
make it start off
maybe up here then it comes down
yeah something like that
and maybe make it come down even more
like that
okay so that's uh one thing the other
thing is like i don't like the line that
crosses over here
so that is in triangle one
right there so to fix that
i'm not going to have it start in here
right so i'm going to go to start offset
and maybe have it start
right there
yeah that works for me that's cool
um i also don't like now that i look at
the lines i don't like how
thin they are um
they're a little bit a little bit too
thin especially this bigger one so let's
go back to core size
and change it to like 1.2
how does that look that's better and
then we're going to go back to the angel
hit you on the keyboard and for the
color
we're gonna do an easy ease in as well
[Music]
and
[Music]
maybe drag those down the timeline like
this
something like that that's cool
okay so something else i want to do is i
want to bring some fog in here
to give it some more atmosphere so what
i
found was right here
under premiumbeat.com they've got 21
free
fog overlays for video editors and
motion designers i will link to this in
the description
you can go here click right here and you
can download the free
fog overlays so i'll go back in after
effects and import them
i've got them imported and like i said i
can't link
i can't give you these fog overlays for
legal reasons
because they're not mine but you can
click and download
those fog overlays yourself
so let's just take a look here scale it
down
originally i had it coming from the left
side so i to do that really easily it's
just negative
58. so now it's coming left to right
so maybe this will work let's see here
let's also make it 3d
and now scale it up
and let's also bring it forward in z
space
so it's in front of the statue
and i've talked about this in videos how
to properly composite fog
for this example i am just going to do a
quick
screen mode so it sits over the top here
i'm also going to back the fog up so it
doesn't start at zero
maybe somewhere in here
and let's drop the opacity down
one other thing i want to do is i don't
want the fog going over the entire image
um i really don't like that so
i will draw a mask
like so very rough
and close it and then i'm going to
feather that mask
by just hitting f on the keyboard to
bring up the mask feather tool
and just dragging it out there see how
that looks
i'm gonna do here is i don't love the
white whiteness of the fog
so we're gonna go into effect color
correction and tritone
effect color correction tritone and
we're not going to apply that to the
angel
whoops we're going to apply that to the
fog
and for the color let's make it that
that's kind of interesting right there
kinda like that purplish pink color
and just to see what it looks like i'm
gonna turn off the mask really quickly
yeah that's way too much
maybe something like this even bring it
down a little bit more
like so
[Music]
okay and actually let's
bring it up like this
well no it's not i thought about
applying the fog to the top and the
bottom but
closer here to the bottoms a little bit
more interesting let's also go to layer
new adjustment layer
and let's add a vignette here
which is under uh generate
sorry stylize
cc vignette let's crank the amount up
oh like so
[Music]
sometimes you can get some really
interesting results with pen highlights
but
this one's not so much
and then for the center position i'm
actually going to drag it up
so i just don't want to see the feet so
much right
like this
you know what would actually be really
cool
if we started the center point
lower down here and then
as the animation progresses because
these lights are coming on
the vignette moves upwards like this
like it's lighting up the area
like so
cool let's take a look at this okay so
here i am previewing at half res
and again immediately i see the fog
moving here and i don't like it it's
way too quick because everything in this
animation is moving at a slower pace the
camera's moving in slow the lights are
coming on slow
the lines are drawing on slower the fog
just throws it all
off so i need to slow down the fog
or find something different for the fog
which i'm thinking maybe i should find
something different from the fog
let's see here what do we got
there's fog whis this could be kind of
cool
thick rolling actually how about ground
fog
thick let's try that and i'm just
holding down option
and dragging to replace the footage
in my timeline
so that's cool um it's a little bit
bright so if i'm at 100 brightness here
um i could go into
uh color correction let's do curves
let's do curves here
kind of bring down
some of that brightness
and let's see how quickly this fog is
moving
so again it's a little too quick so the
easy fix to this is just to stretch it
out
um
so it's longer here maybe 300 percent
see how this looks
yeah i like the speed of that a lot
better now because this is ground fog i
want to look at something here because a
lot of times ground fog
doesn't go all the way up the full
length of the
oh this one does
actually i don't mind that so much
so i'm gonna do here is i like uh the
fog overall i don't like it as much on
the top here
so here's a trick for you let's
take this mask let's rotate it around so
it's upside down
okay and let's
take these points here
pull them down and we're going to set
these to
subtract yeah so we got a just a high
high feather here so we're going to turn
up the feather even more
and take these
maybe something like so maybe it should
kind of come up around
like this
and i'll turn down the opacity just a
little bit trial and error here trial
and error
so it's just very subtle in there
maybe it's too subtle turn it back up
off on off on yeah that could work
so that's looking pretty cool um in the
original version i did not do this
but let's go into our favorite
chromatic warp chroma
and just see just curious how it looks
on this one
that's really crazy that's pretty cool
now that's actually really cool i like
that a lot
let me try and drag it below this is
the vignette
this is the chroma and
this is the green
yeah now it almost has like kind of that
you know 80s
vibe going on a little bit with the uh
chroma
at the default so pretty cool stuff
um let me try one more thing here
just to see because we did talk about
glints
let's go back into lighting glint
and we'll take that below the chroma
and we'll add a preset here
that's pretty cool right there that's
the default
that's really cool
i just love all the presets they're such
a great place to start
we used this one in a previous week
that's really cool
so i'm going to say accent there or this
one which i actually really like that
one
so with without with
without um gives it a very ethereal
feel with that on there doesn't it
yeah i'm digging that
it's just a little bit too much
so we will turn down the brightness just
a tad here
maybe just a little bit more there
subtleties right yeah there we go
awesome and working with this i need to
turn it up to full res
and there we go awesome
okay i'm going to preview this and check
it out okay so there it's going uh it's
looking
really cool actually once again like
this better than my original version
um i don't like that line starting up
here how you saw that
i really love the halo coming down i
love the glint we added
again you can see the line starts off
here that's just a mistake so i'll fix
that so it starts here moves
below there uh in the original version i
also had a line that went
over the top of the angel so maybe i'll
add that really quickly
but i really love the fog that's going
on here um
it's actually almost too slow right or
it's um
it's actually almost too dark so maybe
i'll brighten that up just a tad bit
here
it's already a hundred percent
now let's see let's subtract
let's add some fog in right
through here
yeah let's add that one in
bring up the feather
just a little bit like this
yeah that's cool um and then we've got
to fix the line
[Music]
right there which is
this one nope it's triangle one which is
right here
and it's doing that let's see why is it
doing that
i believe because of the offset
the start offset
nope so it must be the end
offset if we just start it right there
and actually we'll start it at zero
percent right there okay cool so now
there's nothing there
um it'll come on
might be cool actually to see it start a
little bit
into it so it doesn't start right away
that's pretty cool
and then i think i want to do is add
this outer
one here
let's add this on top as well so we'll
duplicate this layer
drag it on top of the angel
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to duplicate the angel take it on
top of the triangle
take the triangle and say alpha matte to
the angel
and if that is the case
but you know what it's because the
position
is too far back so we'll zero out the
position
[Music]
yeah so see it kind of gives it this
offset look which is really cool right
through here
i don't like how it's going across her
head though
it's so funny because you you add things
and then you're like oh why does it do
it like that
why does i have to do that so to fix
that it's because the second mask
is going across there um i'm just going
to delete
that mask
and that still doesn't work for me
hmm
how can we fix that
so that's how it ends up which is too
much
for me it's way too much
um if we turn off this one what happens
here
okay if we delete this one
that's that guy
not a fan of that
okay we'll delete this one we will
delete we will
duplicate the other triangle instead and
try
it alpha matte position it at
zero
wow that's really bright
we'll turn down the core size to one
maybe 1.2
[Music]
and i still don't love that
let me just try something different here
i don't like it
so i'm going to do here is i'm going to
take
this mask drag it down
see how that does
so what is the easy fix here um
let's go back into this triangle again
that we had
duplicate it bring it up here on top
set it to zero
[Music]
duplicate the angel again set the
triangle to alpha matt the angel
let's take a look at this so the thing
that really bothers me about this one is
the
line that goes across here right
so if there's some way we could
eliminate that line and make it down
here it'd be
a lot more look more visually appealing
to me
um so maybe we
[Music]
adjust the start offsets let's just see
what that would do
there's 66 but then there's nothing on
there
um let's adjust the
end offsets
so the main thing here is i just at the
very end when they're all drawn on
i don't want to see this up here
so how can we solve that well here okay
here's an easy fix
i'll go back to my angel layer here and
i will cut out
this part of the angel layer
and we'll do mask
subtract
and that does not work because as you
can see there it looks
terrible so you guys are seeing me
at uh you know this is what it's all
about like
figuring out how do i make it work
how what can i do to make
this work
you know what i actually am okay without
without either one of them on top there
with it just being just like that i'm
cool with that so
that's what i'm gonna go with um
sometimes it's you know better not to
force things and i was
trying to force that one it worked in
the previous example
it did work um in this one it did not
work
so i'm cool with this i actually like it
a lot it looks really great
chromatic aberration added a lot to it
in my opinion with the with the lights
um with the stroke the line
the halo i love it just looks really
great overall so
that's it that's uh this week for color
this is a longer video it's a little bit
more
uh detailed so i'm just sticking with
one video this week
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments below uh as always i really
uh look forward to hearing what you guys
think and what you learn and see what
you guys come up with so
until next week i'm cameron and this is
stylecraft
see ya